[Música]
bienvenidos a reportero es el magazine
de los grandes reportajes de la
redacción de france 24 soy herminia
fernández comenzamos en irving en las
afueras de la capital ucraniana kiev un
movimiento de resistencia multifacético
se prepara para enfrentarse a las tropas
rusas el equipo de reporteros de france
24 acompañó a este grupo integrado por
el artista ucraniano wood am y el
también artista ruso maxim quien ha
decidido quedarse para combatir pese a
que está dividido entre lo que ve en
ucrania y las reprimendas de sus
compatriotas rufus que sólo creen en la
propaganda a favor de putin su hermano
forma parte de las tropas rusas
invasoras no ha tenido noticias suyas
pero sospecha que no está lejos luego
esta serie un miembro ucraniano de la
legión extranjera francesa que ha venido
desde francia para defender su patria
todos ellos juegan un papel en la
defensa de su ciudad a continuación el
informe de cyril payén y georges aspec
[Música]
el ex rey y tu rumbo
es
turismo oye
bueno
[Música]
yo
and sites
o sea
[Música]
y de las medias
has sabido algo de tu familia en rusia
que piensan allá sobre la situación
no me creen es una locura
en moscú mis amigos incluso me dicen
cuánto te están pagando por decir esas
mentiras es como si les estuvieran
suplicando pidiendo ayuda y ellos me
contestan déjate de bromas
ahora lo sé si tengo que hacerlo no lo
dudaré tomaré las armas aquí es donde
vivo y voy a proteger mi casa a mis
amigos ya ti también por supuesto que ha
pasado con tu hermano menor sabes algo
no nada solo sé que estaba enlistado en
el ejército de mi ciudad en rusia
según lo que pude averiguar su unidad se
fue al frente desde el comienzo de la
ofensiva en ucrania
no tengo ningún contacto con él sé que
está ahí en alguna parte allá del otro
lado
a todos los ucranianos que están
refugiados en francia y en el extranjero
no se preocupe vamos a ganar y pronto
todos podrán volver a sus casas
o
para entrar a espn hay que pasar por la
derecha
ese lado está controlado por el ejército
ucraniano
el otro lado del pin está controlado por
los rusos
toma te doy esto para tu granada va a
funcionar si funciona buena suerte
gracias
y vamos a matar a esos malditos rusos
ya has matados rusos
todos los días cuántos
estoy aquí hace 14 días
vivo aquí soy de aquí
mucho cuidado está en el parque justo en
esa calle
[Música]
aquí es peligroso muy peligroso
ahí está su puesto de control esos son
los rusos si hay a 200 metros
ves los tanques
espera un poco
no es una buena idea tenemos que irnos
quien los mató soldados rusos
los rusos empezaron a atacar del otro
lado del parque ahí por el sur
había mucha gente aquí civiles
pero a ellos no les importó disparar a
los civiles
mataban a todo el mundo por siempre
pobres dance que influyó
bienvenidos al infierno
sígueme
mira esto es alcohol y ahora en ucrania
está prohibido tomar alcohol
y
muestra esto
principios
muy bien las apa
y esa firewall
pero
uy
efe donde estas todo va a estar bien
nos estamos expandiendo
para nosotros no hay retorno
no cederemos nada es nuestro país
todos esos invasores rusos bastardos
lamentarán haber venido
haremos abono con sus cadáveres con
buzzi
[Música]
estamos muy seguros
todavía tenemos suficiente comida el
problema es la electricidad
y el agua claro
todo depende de lo que pase después
los rusos no están muy lejos
creo que usted también tendrá que irse
tiene algún plan
no tengo ningún plan
mire tenemos gente aquí nos necesitan
mi pobre perro está en la calle como yo
bombardearon la casa mi amado perro
estamos vivos pero no tengo nada que
darle de comer mi pobre perro
en sleep and live
por qué
[Música]
llegó un grupo de 16 soldados rusos
eran jóvenes reclutas de buriatia el
cura las personas les preguntaron
qué le hizo ucrania a buriatia
porque nos están invadiendo porque
vienen a masacrar a los ucranianos
no contestaron nada
sólo repetían recibimos órdenes tenemos
que obedecer las órdenes
hay cadáveres por todas partes mientras
pasábamos tuvimos que taparle los ojos a
los niños para que no vieran ese horror
acabamos de pasar delante de 20
cadáveres justo ahí en esa calle
no sé cómo se llama esa calle hay 20
cuerpos todos cerca del puente no puede
ser unas pobres personas que iban en
bicicleta tratando de huir es horrible
no tengo palabras ya no soy yo
gracias gracias por estar ahí para
nosotros
rezamos por ustedes liberen nos de los
invasores
los enviaremos al infierno mi hijo
querido rezaré por ti todas las noches
aguantas los queremos igual que a
nuestros hijos
gracias muchas gracias que dios los
protege que se reúnan con sus familias
nuestros héroes gracias
no se preocupe venceremos vamos a ganar
por qué
qué divertido estamos en guerra y
alguien dejo un volante en el parabrisas
que dice estudiantes extranjeros
encuentren un trabajo en quiebra
[Música]
esta es la estatua de la gran figura de
la resistencia bojan que el insee tiki
[Música]
quién es usted estoy con un francés
gloria a ucrania
gloria a los héroes esta plaza donde
estamos es muy importante
es un lugar sagrado para nosotros el
pueblo eslavo a lo largo del tiempo nos
han llamado rust
después rutenos
pero ahora somos ucranianos hemos sido
ucranianos tan sólo desde hace unos 100
años
y estudio nuestra religión nuestra fe es
una fe muy poderosa y central para
nosotros siempre lo ha sido y la
conclusión es muy sencilla si somos
ucranianos es porque hemos resistido
ucrania significa resistencia
[Música]
no no
todo bien si todo está bien estoy listo
estoy listo para la pelea listo para
darlos
el exrector rambo
está muy cercano
esos idiotas están tratando de darnos
están tratando de acabar con nuestra
artillería
pero les vamos a contestar nos vamos a
hacer polvo
todo bien legionario sí todo bien
tranquilo
no están muy lejos verdad está bien
volaron el puente objetivo
[Música]
hasta aquí reporteros de la semana
recuerde que para sintonizar esta y las
ediciones anteriores puede visitar
nuestro sitio web france24 puntocom
hasta la próxima